اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
السودان يستغيث ساعات وتنتهي الهدنه
والتمويل الاممي لا يتجاوز 10% من
احتياجات اللاجئين
وزير الماليه السعوديه يكشف عن حوافز
ضريبيه لمستثمري المناطق الخاصه لمده 20
عاما
تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحق بحرينيين ضماء
لخليه ارهابيه لزعزعه استقرار السعوديه
والبحرين
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
تساؤلات حول شموليه التامين لعلاج
المدمنين الضمان الصحي يكشف عن تغطيته
التشخيص النفسي
ومدينه ابها تستقبل الصيفات بالضباب
استعداد لموسم سياحي ضخم جنوبي السعودي
حياكم الله ايام صعبه يعيشها السودان في
ظل اوضاع انسانيه صعبه وصراع مستمر المفوض
الاممي لشؤون اللاجئين اوضح ان التمويل
المتوفر لا يتجاوز العشر بالمئه من
احتياجات اللاجئين السودانيين هذا ويعقد
طرف النزاع جوله محادثات جديده في جده
لبحث تمديد الهدنه التي تنتهي اليوم مصادر
من وفد التفاوض السوداني كشفت ان الوفد
سيتقدم بملاحظات واشتراطات قبل الدخول في
اي اتفاق مع الدعم السريع وقبل توجه
الوفود الى جده شدد بيان سعودي امريكي
مشترك على اهميه تمديد الهدنه ووقف النار
لمنح المنظمات الانسانيه فرصه لايصال
المساعدات
وبتصريح لقناه العربيه اكدت اللجنه العليا
لمعالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه في السودان
حرصها على الالتزام باعلان جده لحمايه
المدنيين وكذلك تطبيق كافه البنود الوارده
في اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالعمل الانساني وايصال المساعدات موضحه
التزامها بتسهيل دخول وحركه العاملين في
الحقل الاغاثي بحريه داخل وخارج البلاد
ومنحهم تاشيرات الدخول والتصاريح اللازمه
كما امنت على استمرار عمل اللجنه من خلال
تيسير الاجراءات الخاصه بدخول المساعدات
من الموانئ والمطارات وامكانيه نقلها
وتوزيعها وفقا لخارطه الاحتياجات في
الولايات المتاثره بالازمه وشددت على
ضروره تسهيل المسارات وعدم التعرض لقوافل
المساعدات الانسانيه وازاله مظاهر الوجود
العسكري في مناطق التجمعات السكنيه هذا
وفي مكالمه هاتفيه بحث وزير خارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع نظيره
البريطاني جيمس كليفر لجهود المملكه
الهادفه الى دعم الحلول السياسيه في
السودان الطرفان اكد على ضروره تقريب
الاطراف السودانيه وجهات النظر في مفاوضات
جدا كما وناقش الجانبان سبل تعزيز وتطوير
العلاقات بين البلدين واوجه تكثيف التنسيق
المشترك تجاه العديد من القضايا
من دبي تنضم الينا المتحدثه الاقليميه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه هاله غريت مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه
لماذا فشلت اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان حتى الان
مرحبا وشكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه لا
يمكننا نقول انه فشلت يعني شفنا بعد
التقدم خلال وقفه خلال الاتفاق ولكن صحيح
انه كان هناك مخالفات كثيره
ونحن مع شركائنا السعوديين نراقب هذا عن
كثب يعني راينا انه الجيش السوداني قام
بهجمات الجويه راينا انه قوه الدعم السريع
دخلوا الى اماكن مدنيه يعني دخلوا الى
منازل الناس يعني صحيح انه هناك كان كثير
من
المخلفات والانتهاكات ولكن كان هناك كذلك
كذلك
ايامات او ساعات هدنه وهذا كان مهم جدا
لوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وبالنسبه كيف
تراقبون وقفه اطلاق النار في السودان اذا
لم يكن هناك اصل المراقبون على الارض
عندنا اليات مختلفه يعني عندنا مراقبه
جويه وكذلك عندنا شركائنا وحلفاؤنا
شركاؤنا يعني منظمات غير حكوميه الى اخر
داخل داخل البلد ونحن نرى عن كثب ونحن
نعرف ماذا يحصل داخل البلد
والبيان المشترك اللي ارسلنا مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه امبارح يعني كلمنا
بتحديد ماذا يحصل داخل البلد وهذه كانت
رساله للجهتين انه نحن نراقب عن كسل ماذا
يحصل داخل البلد لا يمكنهم يعني داخل داخل
الفنادق يتكلمون على اتفاق وعلى احترام
والاتفاق ولكن بعد ذلك يقوموا بانتهاكات
نحن نراقبون هذا ونحن نرى ماذا يحدث داخل
البلد ولازم محاسبات لهذا كمان ولازم لازم
تمديد هذا الاتفاق لان لازم يعني مساعدات
الانسانيه يدخل الى السودان الان هذا اهم
شيء سناتي على نقطه تمديد الهدنه لكن
تحدثي قبل قليل عن العواقب ونسال عن عواقب
انتهاك وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الطرفين ما
هي الادوات التي
ستستخدمونها في وقف هذا الانتهاك تتحدثون
منذ فتره عن ادوات اخرى
سمعنا الرساله واضحه من رئيس بايدن ومن
وزير بلينك الولايات المتحده عندها اليات
مختلفه منها العقوبات ونحن ندرس كل كل
الاليات امامنا منها العقوبات
ولكن الان نركز كذلك عن هذه
الاتفاق
ولان كان هناك بعض التقدم
نريد تمديد هذه الهدنه لان نحن الان
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده نراكز اولا على
الشعب السوداني لا نريد ناخذ اي اجراءات
سيزيد الى معاناه الشعب السوداني لذلك نحن
ندعو تمديد هذه هذا الاتفاق
لوصول مساعدات الانسانيه داخل البلد الان
يعني هناك من الطرفين هناك ربما اشتراطات
طلبات ايضا كما ذكرنا في الخبر قبل قليل
لتمديد هذه الهدنه كيف تنظرون لهذه
الاشتراطات هل يمكن تربيه اي اشتراطات هل
يمكن ان يكون هناك يعني دعينا نقول
مقابل لهذه الهدنه من الطرفين
لا يمكن ان يدخل في في فرضيات بالنسبه
لهذا ولكن ممكن ممكن اؤكد انه يعني لازم
الطرفين يفكروا في في الشعب السوداني نعرف
الان انه هناك مئات الاف الذين عبروا
الحدود هناك اكثر من مليون نازح داخل
البلد سمعنا اخبار اليوم انه كان هناك
اكثر من خمسين طفل ماتوا
بسبب هذا هذا الصراع الوحشي يعني الوقت
الان ليس شروط الوقت يفاكروا على الشعب
السوداني الذي يعاني الان من هذا هذا
الصباح طيب هناك ايضا سؤال يطرح يعني هل
تخططون في الاداره الامريكيه لاي اشراف
دولي متعدد الجنسيات في
السودان
لوقف القتال لارساء هذه
الهدن بدلا من الوضع القائم الحالي الذي
وصفتيه بالوضع الوحشي او الوضع الصعب او
المتازم
يعني بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الحل لازم
يكون السوداني السوداني وقبل هذا الصراع
مبدا كان هناك مفاوضات بين كل الجهات
المعنيه القوات العسكريه والقوات وكذلك
الجهات المدنيه وكان هناك تقدم قبل هذا
الصراع يعني السفير الامريكي جان جري كان
يشتغل للنهار الان كذلك اشتغل ليل ونهار
هو مازال في السعوديه
وبكون بتنسيق مع كل حلفائنا والشركاؤنا
لنساعد يعني حل سوداني سوداني لهذه الازمه
ولكن يعني لازم تخاف تتصعيد العنف والكتال
ليس الحل هذا فقط يؤدي الى يعني معانا
الشعب السوداني وليس الى اي حل خالص لازم
تمدير هذه الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار
لمساعدات الشعب السوداني الان اذا لم تثبت
هذه الهدنه لم يتم الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار هل سيتم اللجوء بالفعل للعقوبات
مباشره
يعني لا يمكنني ادخل في في فرضيات كما قلت
يعني يوم يوم الى يوم نرى ماذا يحصل داخل
داخل البلد الان وفي مباحثات يعني يوميا
كل ساعه مع كل الجهات المعنيه نحن كذلك مع
التنسيق مع الاتحاد الافريقي يعني هم
عندهم يعني فكره كذلك اللي حل هذه الازمه
ونرى كل الادوات قدامنا
لنساعد الوضع داخل هذه المحادثات برعايه
سعوديه وعلى ارض ايضا كذلك سعوديه وطبعا
بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مع الخارجيه الامريكيه ايضا اريد السؤال
عن الدور السعودي اليوم في هذه الازمه
السودانيه في تقريب وجهات النظر في ارساء
الهدن او وقف اطلاق النار ايضا كذلك كيف
تنظرون اليه
مهم جدا يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
شريك وحليفه في هذا الملف ويعني نشكر كل
جهود الذي تبذل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالنسبه للملف السوداني الان كما قلت
النفير الامريكي هو ما زال في جده
يعني في اللجنه التنسيق ومراقبه وقفه
اطلاق النار ونحن نشتغل مع حلفائنا
السعوديين يد في يد لنشوف حل الى هذه
الازمه داخل السودان اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
دبي انضمت الينا المتحدثه الاقليميه باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
جزيلا
في السودان ايضا تتفاقموا ازمه الخبز بسبب
الحرب في ظل شح الدقيق في المخابز التي
اغلقت كثير منها ابواب ما دفع الى اصطفاف
طابره طويله من المواطنين امام المخابز
العامله حيث يضطر كثيرون للوقوف لساعات
للحصول على رغيف فيما لجا اخرون الى
المنتجات البديله للخبز من مصنعه الدقيق
والدره
وكان ازمات السودان تطول ولا تخسر تتجدد
كل حين لكن بظروف مختلفه هذه المره اقلقت
كثير من المخابز ابوابها بعض 40 يوم من
اندلاع الحرب في الخرطوم الاختتال
والانتشار العسكري ادى لنفاذ الدقيق داخل
المخابز والى توقف الامداد الوقوف
والانتظار لساعات طويله بات هو السبيل
الوحيد المتاح للحصول على خبز هناك مقفله
دقيقه يعني اسيل احنا شغال في
الرابع هنا الصباح ليوم الليله الساعه
قريب ما شاء الله قربت ولا يعني كل يوم
انت بتصبح الصباح انه الحكايه متعزمه يعني
متازيه ومتزمه الافران في تكفيل زياده كل
يوم وسنكفرهم غافل زياده في ازمه بتاعه
صفوف ثقيله فصاحب من الساعه سته طبعا مشيت
فالوضعك صعب يعني
لا يبدو ان هناك حلولا عمليه لصد النقص اذ
ان اغلاق المخابز ستواصل فيها كذا اوضاع
حسبما يقول اصحابها المشاكل في الدقيق
الغاز ما في وفرض الدقيقه اللي عندنا ما
تقضي يوم ولا يوم الثاني
ما في وجود للغاز ولا ولا الدقيق ولا
للخميره
في ظل شحي وصعوبه الحصول عليه لجا عددا من
السودانيين الى بدائل قديمه حلها تعوض
صعوبه الحصول عليه فقد تسيدت منتجات الذره
مواعيد عدد كبير من المواطنين
كلها بقت في شح في الحاجات دي المهم كل
شيء ما في الوضع صعب جدا جدا
اقلقت كثير من مخابز الخرطوم ابوابها امام
المواطنين لكنهم يعملون رغم تطاول امضى
الحرب ان تظل ابواب اخرى مفتوحه امامهم
لمنحهم قدره الاكمال والاستمرار شوفد نادر
لقناته العربيه والحدث اندرمان
الرابع مستمر وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
وزير الماليه السعودي يكشف عن حوافز
الضريبيه لمستثمري المناطق الخاصه لمده 20
عاما
حياكم الله من جديد تخفيضات ضريبيه لمده
20 عاما ستقدمها السعوديه للمستثمرين وفقا
لتاكيدات وزير الماليه السعودي محمد
الجدعان في منتدى في منتدى الاستثمار في
المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه
خلال ذات الجلسه ضمن منتدى الاستثمار في
المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه في السعوديه
اعلن وزير الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه احمد الراجحي ان احد الحوافز
التي تقدمها المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه هي
الاعفاء من متطلبات السعوده
[موسيقى]
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو رئيس الجزائر
اولا عن هذه الحوافز والتخفيضات ايضا
الضريبيه التي تم الاعلان عنها اليوم وش
اللي ستضيف هذه
التخفيضات او هذه الحوافز من ميز تنافسيه
داخل المناطق الجغرافيه ومنها جازان طبعا
مدينه جازان الاقتصاديه رئيسيه
للتجاره العالميه لتمر 13% منها من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولا نحييك اخوي نايف المشاهدين الكرام
اليوم حنا صراحه سعيدين باطلاق المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخاصه
من هنا نوجه شكرنا لكل من قام بهذا العمل
على اطلاق المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه وعلى
راسها وزاره الاستثمار
بالنسبه لجازان
والحوافز اللي تكلمت عنها الحوافز هي لكل
المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه ولكن بالنسبه
لجازان
فهي تتميز بموقع الجغرافي مميز
للمستثمرين فالان الحمد لله حنا جاهزين
لجميع المستثمرين من بنيه تحتيه
وميناء جاهز الان الحمد لله واصبح يصدر
ويستورد المستثمرين موجودين في المدينه في
مستثمرين الان عندنا مستثمرين الحمد لله
في المدينه والحوافز هذه اللي اطلقت اليوم
الحمد لله بتجيب مستثمرين بشكل اكبر
وهي حواف الصراحه مميزه
اها والعالم الان شوف اي مستثمر عشان يبدا
في العمل في المناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه
ايش اللي يحتاجه بني تحتيه بورت ميناء
للتصدير والاستيراد اضيف في جيزان ان غير
الجاهزيه اني عندك ماركه وسوق موجود في
القرن الافريقي وعلى باب المندب موقع
جغرافي هو للسعوديه يربط بين بين ثلاث
قارات فهذه ايضا واحده من الميز حتى اللي
تم الحديث عنها اليوم
كذلك احنا يعني مثل ما نشوف في تغير عالمي
في في مساله مهمه وهي مساله سلاسل الامداد
في اعاده رسم لهذه المساله تحديدا والرسم
خطوط سلاسل الامداد جيزان اين سيكون
موقعها من
يعني مساله الخطوط الجديده لسلاسل الامداد
بعد اطلاق هذه المناطق وهذه الحوافز ايضا
الحمد لله حنا بدانا في موضوع سلاسل
الامداد في جيزان
وبدانا في استلام السفن اللي كانت توصل
الى جده وعلى ما توصل من تاجر الى تاجر
الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
كانت تاخذ وقت وسعر اعلى الان استقبلنا
السفن مثلا للشعير للمزارعين اربع سفن من
الارجنتين وايضا صفر من المانيا فاصبحت
سلاسل الامداد تتجه مباشره الى جزم سفن
بدا من تروح لجده وتجي بالبر
فالجغرافيه الموقع وسلاسل الامداد اصبحت
تتجه السفن مباشره الى جازان لوجود
الميناء وجاهزيته
واصبحت الان تاخذ الفيدرز اللي هي سفن
الصغيره من جده الى جيزان
فهذا سهل الحمد لله حتى في اسعار المنتجات
انها لما توصل الى جزاء مباشره
اقل للمزارعين وتكلفه اقل للتجار يعني
كثير يسال اليوم يقول اليوم المواطن مثلا
اللي على سبيل المثال موجود مثلا في جيزان
كيف ممكن يستفيد من هذه المناطق
الاقتصاديه اصلا كيف ممكن يستفيد من
الشركات الاجنبيه اللي جايه تستثمر في هذه
المناطق واللي لديها اعفاءات ضريبيه عفوا
حوافز ضريبيه وتخفيضات اللي عندها اعفاء
مثلا من متطلبات السعوده كيف بتنعكس على
الناس اللي موجودين في الجزائر هذا سؤال
صراحه مهم جدا واحنا اشتغلنا عليه في
الهيئه الملكيه
الان عندنا اللي هو صناعه الاغذيه عشان
يجي تاجر اجنبي ويبدا في صناعه الاغذيه
وين راح يزرع ما عنده الا يزرع في جيزان
فبدانا في الامور اللاجستيه مع وزاره
الزراعه والايجار الزراعيه واماره المنطقه
وصدرنا في المنطقه القريبه من المدينه من
مدينه جازان لصناعه الاساسيه وتحويليه وهي
مدينه بيشه 21 الف سجل زراعي للمواطنين
عشان تثبت ملكيتهم الزراعيه الان تتجه
الشركات الى المزارعين تاخذ اراضيهم
فيزرع في المنطقه فيستفيد الابناء المنطقه
من المزارعين
اضف الى ذلك انه يعني جازان تتميز بطاقه
بشريه هائله من الشباب اللي راح يشتغلوا
باذن الله في المدينه وفي منطقه
الاقتصاديه
للشباب في
فيلا الان بيصير يعني عندنا
البلان في الماستر بلان 50 الف وظيفه
لابناء المنطقه ولكن على فترات الى الان
لسه
الشركات كل ما تبدا الشركه عندنا تبدا
عمليه السعوده وصلت الى تقريبا عشرين
بالمئه خمسه وعشرين بالمئه ولكن حنا حنا
ننظر الى نقوم بعمليات الحمد لله التدريب
الان في يعني عندنا افكار في بناء
اكاديميه
وبعد التدريب ان تقولون الى الموقع في
المصانع اللي راح تجهز المدينه من ضمنها
المناطق اللي في الاقصاد المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخاصه وبعدها يبدون الحمد لله
بالتوفيق لكم
الرابعه رئيس التنفيذي المكلف لمدينه جزاء
الاقتصاديه حسين فاضلي شكرا لك
اعلنت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه عن تنفيذ
حكم الاعدام بحق جانيين من الجنسيه
البحرينيه وبين الداخليه السعوديه ان
الجانيين اقدم على الانضمام الى خليه
ارهابيه تابعه لكيان ارهابي والتواصل مع
ارهابيين داخل المملكه بهدف زعزعه امن
السعوديه والبحرين وتهريب مواد وكبسولات
تستخدم في التفجير الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وتسليمها لزعيم الخليه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تساؤلات حول شموليه التامين لعلاج
المدمنين وضمان الصحي يكشف عن تغطيته
التشخيص النفسي
حياكم الله من جديد رائده الفضاء
السعوديان ريان برناوي وعلي القرني في
رحله فضائيه تاريخيه شغلت اذهان متابعيها
كيف تاقلما خارج الكره الارضيه وكيف
يقضيان يومهما في المحطه الفضائيه الدوليه
زميل روان حمزه تجيب عن تلك التساؤلات في
العرض الاتي
بعد وصول رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علي
القرني وريانه برناوي لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه بدات مهمتهما العلميه ودارت في
اذهان متابعي الحدث التاريخي اسئله عديده
فقمنا نحن في قناه العربيه بالبحث عن
الاجابات التاليه علي وريان يحملان على
عاتقهما اربع عشره تجربه علميه بمعدل
تجربتين يوميا في بيئه خاصه منها تجارب
بعينات جاهزه مثل اي نوع من انواع
الالتهابات وهناك تجارب تتطرق لصحه
الانسان في الفضاء كالتاقلم مع البيئه او
قياس العلامات الحيويه مثل قياس قطري عصب
العين واخرى مثل عمليات الاستمطار وقياس
تاثيرها وانعكاساتها البيئيه اسئله اخرى
شغلتكم وشغلنا البحث عن اجابتها كيف يتغذى
رائد الفضاء السعوديان خارج الكره الارضيه
مشاهدينا كمال سكان الارض حميات غذائيه
محدده لزوار الفضاء ايضا حم خاصه مكونه من
ثلاث وجبات يوميا محضره باشتراطات ناسا
كيف ينام رواد الفضاء مع انعدام الجاذبيه
واختلاف التوقيت الزمني والبيئه يبدا يوم
رواد الفضاء الساعه الثامنه صباحا وحتى
الساعه السادسه مساء تتخلله اوقات للانشطه
بعدها يحين وقت الراحه داخل حقيبه نوم
خاصه مثبته ماذا عن التواصل مع سكان الارض
الاهل والاصدقاء نعم مسموح لرواد الفضاء
بالتواصل مع من يريدون لكن عبر الاتصال
الصوتي فقط اما المرئي فيخصص للفريق الطبي
واخيرا نطمئن مشاهدينا بان جميع من على
محطه الفضاء مدربون على الاسعافات الاوليه
للتعامل مع اي حالات طارئه لا قدر الله
الحرب على المخدرات في السعوديه تتواصل
وفي اخر الجهود قبضت المديريه العامه
لمكافحه المخدرات على اربعه مقيمين
بالمنطقه الشرقيه لترويج ماده الامبرتيمين
المخدر الشبو واقراص خاضعه لتنظيم التداول
الطبي
تساؤلات متكرره صاحبه الحمله الجاريه
لمكافحه المخدرات في السعوديه حول وثيقه
التامين الصحي وهل تشمل خدمات الرعايه
والعلاج المقدمه للمدمنين مجلس الضمان
الصحي بين ان الوثيقه الاساسيه تغطي
تكاليف الكشف والتشخيص لعلاج الحالات
النفسيه المصاحبه لتعاطي الكحول او
المخدرات لكنه لا يشمل التنويم للتاهيل
وفقا للمجلس
معي هنا في الاستوديو مدير التنفيذي
للتمكين والاشراف والمتحدث الرسمي في مجلس
الضمان الصحي الدكتور ناصر الجاني دكتور
ناصر حياك الله من الرياض حياك الله اخوي
نايف ارحب بك وباستاد المشاهدين خلينا
نسال اولا هل تغطي وثيقه التامين الصحي
الرعايه الشامله للمدمنين الذين ينورون
العلاج من الازمه ببدايه بدمن الجهود التي
تقوم بها الدوله حاليا لمكافحه المخدرات
مجلس الضمان الصحي جهه مكمله لهذه الجهود
اضفنا في التغطيات التامينيه علاج
الادمان للمرضى المصابين به
اضيفت ابتلاء من اكتوبر العام الماضي
والان اصبحت من التامينات الالزاميه
المقطعه مغطاه باي شكل يعني نعم علاج
الادمان الكامل نعم تحت بند الصحه النفسيه
الصحه النفسيه والعقليه نعم وطبعا المغطه
هي علاج الادمان وايضا علاج جميع الحالات
مثل الاكتئاب والقلق لان الكتاب والقلق قد
يؤدي الى الاتمام فبحثنا عن جذور التي قد
تؤدي الادمان وقمنا بتغطيتها التاهيل او
التنويم لعلاج الادمان تحت الدراسه
لاضافته في تحديثات القادمه باذن الله
يعني لسه ما حاليا غير مضاف ولكن تحت
الدراسه لاضافته ان شاء الله في التحديثات
القادمه طيب هل يغطي كل يعني انت عارف انه
التامينات الصحيه تختلف من شخص الى الى
اخر حسب الفئات والدرجات وبشكل مختلف هل
هي متاحه لكل هذه الفئات نعم صحيح طبعا
مجلس ضبان الصحي يحدد الحد الادنى من
التغطيات التامينيه الالزاميه التي يجب ان
تكون في جميع وثائق التامين وهذه التغطيه
موجوده في جميع وثائق التامين كتغطيه
الزمنيه ويعالج الادمان ويعالج ما بعد
الادمان اللي هي الحالات النفسيه
والانسحابيه وغيرها نعم نعم
بشكل عام مغطى من
ضمنها علاج الادمان
اذا شملت علاج الاعراض الانسحابيه
والادويه اللي يحتاجونها لمرضى المصابين
بالادمان جميع مغطاه هل في اي استثناءات
في في هذا الموضوع دكتور ناصر حتى اليوم
المستثني هو
التنويم او التنويم لعمليه التاهيل الى
الان ليست مقطعه ومثل ما ذكرت تحديد
الدراسه ايضا قد المضاعفات التي قد تنشا
من الادمان هذه ايضا تحت الدراسه لتغطيتها
فكره المضاعفات بعد الدراسه يعني ايش ممكن
تشمل مستقبلا نعم وقد بعض المخدرات قد
تؤدي الى امراض
عصبيه
فشل في الكبده وفشل في الكلى او الى اخره
فهذه المضاعفات حتى الان غير مغطاه ولكنها
تحت الدراسه
تضمينها في التحديثات القادمه باذن الله
يعني مجلس الضمان الصحي ينظر للتغطيات
لادراجها في تغطيه بشكل تدريجي ففي كل
تحديث نقوم باضافه تغطيه الزاميه عند
التحديث وصلتكم طلبات من الناس او تعليقات
على الموضوع باضافه التنويم
وانه يشمل ايضا كذلك حتى التاهيل او
الامراض اللي ما بعد العلاج من الادمان
ولا انتو قستوها بحسب الوضع الحالي نعم
جميع درست في التحديث الاخير ولكن مثل ما
ذكرت مجلس الضمان يضيف بشكل تدريجي يعني
احنا كل تحديث نقوم بتحديث تقريبا كل ثلاث
سنوات في كل مره نبدا بزياده بعض المنافع
نضيفه على التحديثات فدرست وبدانا الان
بتغطيه الحالات النفسيه كلها بما فيها
الادمان الى
خمسين الف كانت 15,000 ريال اصبحت الى
خمسين الف ثلاث اضعاف هذا في التغطيه هذا
الحد الادنى نعم حددنا بالتغطيه لا يجوز
لاي شركه تامين بالتغطيه اقل من 50,000
ريال فكانت 15 الف اصبحت ايضا حالات نفسيه
اكثر وايضا تضمين الادمان وايضا في
التحديثات القادمه ان شاء الله نتطلع انه
نضيف منافع اضافيه شركات التامين الصحيه
ايضا كيف تتفاعل مع هذا الموضوع في تجاوب
ولا الموضوع كان صعب شوي نتكلم يعني مثلا
اذا انتم في هالدراسات اللي تتحدث عنها لو
اتخاطبتوا معها تتم الموافقه يعني وايضا
فيما يخص الحد الادنى من 15 الف الى خمسين
الف نعم نعم طبعا حنا نراقب ابتسام شركات
التامين بتضمين هذه المنافع في الوثائق
الجديده والمجدده وايضا الالتزام شركات
التامين بتغطيه هذه الحالات حتى الان لم
نوجه اي تحديات في التغطيه ونراقب هذا
باستمرار عن طريق منصه نفيس المنصه
الموحده للتعاملات التامينيه التي يشرف
عليها مجلس الضمان الصحي يعني ان شاء الله
مستقبلا حاله المدمن حتكون يعني مغطاه
بشكل كامل من العلاج حتى التاهيل حتى
الحالات والامراض اللي ما بعد العلاج من
الادمان نعم باذن الله شكرا جزيلا لك كان
معي هنا في الاستوديو المدير التنفيذي
للتمكين والاشراف متحدث الرسمي في مجلس
الضمان الصحي الدكتور ناصر الجهيني شكرا
يا دكتور شكرا
احتفت السفاره السعوديه لدى الولايات
المتحده بتخريج دفعه جديده من الطلاب
والطالبات السعوديين من جامعه هارفرد
ومعهد ماسه شوس للتكنولوجيا الزميل محمد
شامي هذا الاحتفال تابع
رحله طويله ومتعبه قضاها هؤلاء الخريجون
قبل الوصول الى هذه اللحظه
جامعه هارفرد ومعهد ام اي تي للتكنولوجيا
خرج دفعه جديده من الطلاب منهم 49 سعوديا
وسعوديا
احتفت بهم السفاره السعوديه في واشنطن
بحضور نائب البعثه في الولايات المتحده
الامير مصعب بن محمد الفرحان
[تصفيق]
الحمد لله وطنا يشهد تقدم غير مسبوق في
مختلف المجالات
الوطن ينتظركم المسؤوليه عليكم كبيره
الامان المعقوده فيكم وانتم اهل لها افضل
المؤسسات التعليميه هدف رئيس الاستراتيجيه
الابتعاث المحدثه التي تنتهجها السعوديه
لمخرجات مقرونه بالمنجزات العلميه
والبحثيه هو برنامج الرواد والذي يركز على
افضل 30 جامعه في المستوى العالم في
التخصصات شتى تركز على برامج الرقيه
سعيدين جدا عندنا كوكبه رائعه من ابناء
وبناء الوطن يدرس في افضل الجامعات في
العالم وفي امريكا ايضا اكثر من 100 طالب
سعودي ما زالوا على مقاعد الدراسه في
هارفرد ومعهد ام اي تي للتكنولوجيا بتوع
ثوث 32 تخصصا فريدا
على الطلاب بالجمعيه اللي هي هسه
كان عندها 103 عندنا حول 75 طالب من
البقيه من كان عندنا اكثر من 27 تخصص فريد
من نوعه في الهندسه في القانون سبعه اعوام
هي عمر النادي السعودي في هارفرد الذي دشن
عام 2016
ويعتبر موطنا لقاده المستقبل والمبتكرين
ومنصه تفاعليه بين طلاب الجامعه
ايام قليله عن بدء موسم سياحي صيفي ضخم في
ابهى جنوب السعوديه درجات حراره عشرينيه
ضباب كثيف غطى اليوم معظم الطرقات المؤديه
الى المواقع والمنشات السياحيه
[موسيقى]
اتوقف الان مع هذه الصور من شلالاتي جبال
بجده في مدينه نيويورك شمال غربيه
السعوديه بعد الامطار التي اطلت اليوم
[موسيقى]
خلال هذا الاسبوع ستكون الشمس هي القبله
وقت اذان الظهر على الحرم المكي خاصه في
ايام السبع والعشرين والثامن والعشرين
والتاسع والعشرين من مايو التفاصيل في
تقويم مع خالد
[موسيقى]
القبله هي وجهه المصلي وبيت المقدس هي
قبله المسلمين قبل هجره النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وفي 17 رجب من السنه الثانيه
للهجره تحولت القبله من بيت المقدس الى
مكه المكرمه والقبله تحدث عن طريق النجوم
في الليل وعن طريق الشمس في النهار فالشمس
اساسا في تحديد مواقيت الصلاه وتحديد
القبله اراني اذا صليت يممت نحوها بوجه
وان كان المصلى ورائيه وما به اشراك ولكن
حبها وعظم الجوى اعيا الطبيب
المداويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وخلال هذا الاسبوع الشمس تكون هي القبله
وقت اذان الظهر على الحرم خاصه في يوم 27
28 29 مايو فالشمس في هذا الوقت الساعه
12:27 دقيقه تكون فوق الكعبه على مستوى
العالم بمعنى ان الذي يشاهد الشمس سواء
كان عندهم صبح او ظهر او عصر فهو مستقبل
للقبله والشمس تكون فوق الكعبه او تمر على
الكعبه مرتين بسنه مره وهي طالعه فوق
لمدار سرطان في 27 مايو ومره ثانيه وهي
نازله تحت لمدار الجدي في 16 يوليو قد نرى
تقلب وجهك في السماء فلا نولينك قبله
ترضاها هو اللي وجهك شطر المسجد الحرامي
وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم شاطره
[موسيقى]
حذرت دراسه حديثه نشرها المرصد الفرنسي
للاغراق المعلوماتي والتعاون الرقمي من
الادوات التكنولوجيه التي اصبحت تشغل
مساحه اكبر في اماكن العمل حيث تؤدي دورا
مساعده للموظفين في القيام بمهامهم لكنها
تحمل ايضا مخاطر الاجهاد الرقمي
ذو الاجهزه الالكترونيه في البيوت
والاماكن العامه والاكثر في مقرات العمل
خاصه مع الاعتماد عليها بشكل شبه كامل
دراسه حديثه حذرت من هذه التكنولوجيا
مشيره الى ان
31% من الموظفين
يفرطون في استخدامها ما قد يؤدي الى حاله
عزله بسبب الضغط الذهني فلا يوم عمل يمر
دون ارسال بريد واستقبال اخر
قلبت الحياه اذا ما قلنا سهلتها ولكن هل
تنقلب الى نقمه الاطباء حذروا من حمى
التكنولوجيا فالاجهاد الرقمي برايهم بات
خطرا اخذا في التمدد لا سيما عقب جائحه
كورونا التي اجبرت الكثيرين على المكوث
طويلا خلف الشاشات حد الاعتماد عليها في
شتى المجالات اي انها مشقه رقميه كما اطلق
عليها
مرتبطه بامراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه
فضلا عن التمثيل الغذائي والتاثيرات
المناعيه الى جانب الضغط النفسي الذي يقلل
من الاداء المهني
قبل الختام تذكير بابرز عناوين الرابعه
السودان يستغيث ساعات وتنتهي الهدنه
التمويل الاممي لا يتجاوز 10% من احتياجات
اللاجئين
بورتنتس
وزير الماليه السعوديه يكشف عن حوافز
ضريبيه لمستثمري المناطق الخاصه لمده 20
عاما
حكم او تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحق بحرينيين
ضمان خليه ارهابيه لزعزعه استقرار
السعوديه والبحرين
تساؤلات حول شموليه التامين لعلاج
المدمنين والضمان الصحي يكشف عن تغطيته
التشخيص النفسي
مدينه ابها تستقبل الصيف بالضباب استعداد
لموسم سياحي ضخم جنوبي السعودي
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات